President Trump is traveling to two
cities devastated by mass shootings this
past weekend where people offended by
his words are questioning his plans El
Paso's Republican mayor says it's his
duty to meet with the president despite
calls for mr. Trump to stay home some
Democrats and others there say the
president's tough talk on illegal
immigration enables violence like the el
paso shootings the alleged white
supremacist who is charged with killing
22 people wrote that he was responding
to what he called the Hispanic invasion
of Texas those words are similar to the
ones President Trump has used I declared
a national emergency which is what it is
this is an invasion when you see these
caravans starting out with 20,000 people
that's an invasion I was badly
criticized for using the word invasion
it's an invasion another nine people
were killed in Dayton Ohio where
Democratic mayor nan Whaley will meet
with mr. President Trump this morning
she said yesterday she was disappointed
with the president's statement on the
shootings Monday near nan Whaley joins
us now
good morning mayor and our deepest
condolences to your community thank you
for being with us Thank You Anthony what
do you plan to say to President Trump
today
well I hope I get a couple of seconds or
a couple of minutes just to ask him to
not only just come here to comfort
victims and our first responders but
actually to take some action
we had a vigil on the street Sunday
night at 8 o'clock and the grief and
anger and love actually was palpable but
the anger is something that I think has
motivated a lot of politicians here in
Ohio to take action and instead of just
words I want the president to to do
something to make sure that these kind
of senseless acts of violence stop
happening in the country madam mayor
when you say do something what would you
like the president to do you mentioned
the action there your own governor has
proposed now some gun control reforms
that he'd like to see in place right in
the past 48 hours we've seen the
Republican governor move forward on
legislation around background checks and
rad flag laws we've seen the Republican
congressman here call for the end of
these assault weapons I'm pleased with
all of those those efforts the president
has a choice of lots of options to take
actions to make sure that these
senseless gun crime these guns which are
legal right now these senseless gun
actions slow down one example is the the
red flag law that Lindsey Graham and
Blumenthal have moved forward he could
support that and say I'm going to I'm
going to do everything it's president to
make that happen
we know the president is someone that
relishes action
but we've seen no action around gun
issues just a lot of talk Mara Whaley
the gunman's family released a statement
saying that they are cooperating with
law enforcement have you learned
anything new about the gunman's motives
we haven't yesterday afternoon the FBI
took over that section of the
investigation because of some of the
violent ideologies is what they've what
they've talked about but they've also
said that they're pretty confident that
it's not racially motivated so we'll
leave that to the federal investigators
to really under that you went to two
hospitals to visit some of the shooting
survivors and the medical teams how is
everyone holding up look it's tough you
know when I went to visit the folks that
were injured they had you know lost a
friend their other friends were there so
this is like not just one person that
just was sitting here and nobody was
else surrounded so their whole network
of folks have had great trauma around
what happened Saturday night and that's
going to take some time for our
community a lot of a lot of those
injured are just processing not really
understanding you know really what
happened and you know look though the
whole community is still processing that
we have survivors all over this
community there were over thousands of
people here in the district Saturday
night like a normal Saturday night so
we're all in that process but certainly
the the families who lost loved ones and
those that have been injured are people
that we're paying very close attention
to here in Dayton mayor Whaley
unfortunately so many have been in your
shoes before have you gotten any advice
that may help you as you try to lead
your community in healing now yeah the
the mayor's across the country have been
terrific not surprisingly you know
mayors are the last functioning part of
government so Bill Peduto Pittsburgh has
been in touch with me every single day a
Christine Hough chomsky the mayor of
Parkland has been amazing mayor caster
down in Tampa Florida it used to be a
police chief has been awesome and Buddy
Dyer of Orlando with the pulse nightclub
unfortunately this is a fraternity that
we wish didn't exist but I am so
grateful for the mayors across the
country their leadership and their want
an action to finally make it so we don't
have to have another city that continues
to go through with this you have that
list just far too long
mayor Whaley thank you
again our condolences to all of you
there in Dayton thank you